- On this episode,
Black Coffee stops by.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 255,
we think, of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
We are in a beautiful
setting here in Cannes
at the Advertising Festival
but way more important than that
we're hanging with
some of our favorite friends
but way more
important than that,
we have music superstar
Black Coffee in the house
with his epic light blue pants
and his massive skills.
Black Coffee, my man.
First of all, great to see you.
Why don't you
tell the Vayner Nation
that's watching right now,
for the people that
have been living under a rock
before we get into the questions
that are coming
through Facebook.
Great to see you start
firing away your questions.
Why don't you tell
for a minute or two,
not only what you do but a
little bit of the backstory
which I'm very fond of,
of how you've
gotten to this point
and what you do for a living.
So fire away.
- I'm basically, I'm a music guy
born in South Africa.
Studied music, dropped out,
started a band, dropped out,
started my solo career
as a music producer and a DJ.
Been doing this
for over 10 years now.
Yeah.
- That's how, that's it?
- That's it.
- So on a very serious note,
what's really interesting is
I'm fortunate enough to hang
out with a lot of fun people
but the selfie that you
and I took 18 months ago,
the passion of your
audience is so incredible.
When people saw that we
were hanging out together,
they were like,
it blew their mind
and I have been following along
since the day I've met you
with your career and
things of that nature.
It's incredible
to watch the passion
that your fan base has.
Why do you think
you've broken out
and actually because again
I wanna make sure people know.
How do you define your genre?
'Cause I think you do
it a little bit different
and I wanna just hear
it from the horse's mouth.
How do you define your
style of DJing and music?
- I just call it house music.
One guy literally
yesterday was asking me,
"I know it's house
but what kind of house?"
And I try not to go there.
- On purpose?
- Yeah.
- You feel like you get boxed?
- I don't want it to be, yeah.
I don't want it
to be pigeonholed
into any genre of house.
I just call it house music.
And it's different at times,
a bit tribal,
sometimes with African,
sometimes it's a
bit jazzy, more RnB-ish,
more house, but
it is house music.
- So well actually
let's take a step back.
When did you realize as a
youngster you loved music?
Was it when you were,
right away from the womb?
Later in life?
- When I was a kid,
basically I just
loved dancing to music.
And then growing up,
one of my cousins and his friend
had like a mobile
disco sound system.
I used to go with them,
help them connect
the system at parties
and anything that had
music I would be there.
I didn't know what
I really wanted to do.
When they introduced
the music class in school,
I was the first
one to go in there.
Still I didn't know.
I went to study,
I listen to the music next door.
I studied jazz music.
And even then I didn't
know what I would do.
But there was a music studio
which I really loved
working on music production
more than anything.
And I think that's
where the production work
started shaping up.
- And as you were going
through this music journey
who were the one, two, three,
influences you
think in your music life?
I'm always fascinated
by who people listen to
or what was the song
or who was the producer.
What were some of
those keystone individuals
and/or moments in
your music journey?
- I think as a,
at an early age
I just,
sort of visualized
myself on a global scale.
I used to have dreams of then
working with Michael Jackson,
as a kid in Africa.
- Right.
- I used to have,
daydream about him
and me being friends,
and he would come to
South Africa for his show
and we'd hang out.
I think he's one of the people
that played a major role.
I listened to a lot of the stuff
that he was
doing with Quincy Jones
very early and
just watched his career
and many others.
From an early age
I've always had that
global ambition.
- You know it's funny,
you have a piece of content
that caught my attention
where it's a
drone coming in and out
and you referenced,
you referenced there
I think as a kid
I daydreamed a lot,
I was in my head a lot.
- Yeah.
- And this is
now the second time.
So is that what you were doing?
When you were sitting there,
is that what
you were just doing?
You were dreaming it out?
You were picturing
what it was gonna look like?
- Everything, man.
- With you and
Michael Jackson being homies?
- Yeah, man.
Every, it was
the craziest thing.
- Where were you guys?
Were you in
California, in Neverland?
- That's the thing.
I was in a
township in South Africa.
Almost rural place
called the Eastern Cape,
almost, almost rural.
I say that because
my grandmother had cows
so I grew up
milking cows literally.
And on holidays I would
be like the shepherd boy.
I would look after the cows.
That's where the
daydreaming was taking place,
in the field when
I'm sitting with the cows
and that's how I would
spend my holidays.
- I love that.
So before we get
into some of the questions
that are coming
through on social,
what was kind of the break,
it's obviously been,
overnight success
takes your whole life,
but was there a,
there's a lot of
entrepreneurs that are watching,
a lot of creators,
a lot of artists,
I think for everybody
there is always moments.
It might not,
for me I never think
of it as the one thing
but it's been seven or
10 or 11 different things.
Do you remember the first thing
that kind of
changed the outcome?
Obviously you mentioned earlier
you've tried a
couple things in the past.
They didn't work out.
For the thing that did work out,
did somebody put you on?
Did somebody play a song?
What was the moment
where you first tasted,
okay, there's
something happening here.
- I think when I got
accepted to study music
at a university level.
I then thought, okay
I might have something.
'cause it was the
most weird thing for me.
I can't really sing but they
interviewed me as a singer.
So they asked me to sing
and that's how I got in.
So I majored in jazz voice.
So that's, for me that was,
okay, maybe I do have something.
And then while we were studying,
then we were signed as a band
by a label from London.
That was also
another step to say okay,
we actually do
have something going.
Those two steps for me
were the most important,
in terms of just knowing,
okay, I don't
know what I'm doing
but I am in the right direction.
- What about your
relationship with social?
You have a really
substantial following.
Does that come native to you?
As somebody who's
been sitting with the cows
and in your own
head as a framework,
has the outward
aspect of the fame
or the hundreds of
thousands of millions of fans
that follow you
on these platforms.
Has that come natural?
Is that something
that you've had to develop?
Do you like it?
Do you not like it but
you recognize the importance
in what you do for a living?
Talk to me about
that relationship.
- I love that relationship.
I respect it a lot.
I see it as a great platform
to talk to my people a lot.
Also because I'm hardly
in South Africa any more.
You know, at times
I feel like I'm detached
from everything that's
happening, from the fan base.
And for me it's very
important to be accessible.
You know, it's very
important for me to
talk to them and
make them understand that
whatever that I'm
doing they can do it.
So it helps me close
that gap and I'm able to talk.
Like today my tweet was
"What did you do today to
"to get closer to the
life that you deserve?"
That was my tweet today,
and it got a lot of traction
because it was a
genuine question.
And that's what
I try and post about.
I post about real things.
There's a line though, you know.
There's a very thin line,
'cause there's a real life
and then there's
a real personal life
and I try separate
the personal things
'cause I don't think
they'll motivate some people.
Sometimes they can just
kill their spirits as well.
So I try to be
as real as possible
and I use my
social media platforms
all the time to post
things that can only build.
'Cause you must
remember, I'm from South Africa
and we have a very
turbulent past as a country.
And it effected a lot of
our parents and
our great grandparents.
And they didn't have
much to give us, you know,
even in terms of
drive and motivation.
So we are building as
a country at the moment.
We try to find our feet,
and it's always important to
push that message
that, guys remember,
we are far from where
the rest of the world is.
I try so hard to use my social
media to communicate such.
- Love it.
Lindsay is gonna ask the
questions here today DRock.
So Linds ...
- Hello, testing.
Okay, so first the live
stream is a little--
so the live stream
is a little spotty.
- Okay. But do
you have questions?
- They're all asking
- [Gary] Okay.
- So Roy (mumbles) wants to
know what's more beneficial
being a jack of all
trades or being a master of one?
- For me, growing up,
music was definitely my thing.
Like this is all I do, you know.
And, but I have
love for art, you know.
I've given love
for other things.
You know, and not everyone
can be a master of everything,
but if you have
the talent I think
that's what it boils down to.
To have the talent
of doing other things.
One of the reasons why Gary
inspires me so much,
is the fact that he's not just
one minded or
his business is
only on one direction.
You know, he does
so many different things
and he does all
of them with passion
and I think that's
the most important thing.
I draw so much from him
and many other people who,
like Virgil Abloh
who's an architect
and a clothing designer
and so many other things.
If you have the
talent and the drive
to be able to
master what you know
then don't stop
because you are afraid
to be tagged as
a master of none.
I just think if the
talent is there, go on.
- I'll add on that.
I think self-awareness
matters so much, right?
Like, I think that there's a
lot--
I mean I look and
I know a lot of you
a lot or a
little bit from a far,
I'm sure we all
aspire for other things
that we could have
done or wanted to be
especially when
we're hangin around
with our friends and
things of that nature,
but the reality is you've
gotta realize what you are.
And I also think
that one can judge,
it's subjective if you're
the master of a certain thing
or you're doin a whole
bunch of different things.
So, for me,
I appreciate those kind words.
And it's funny for me,
all the things I do,
and I do so many
different things,
but ironically, for me,
they're actually just
a heavy reliance on empathy,
which then leads to
being a good salesman
because if you
understand other people
and what they want
you're deploying against that.
And then I'm just
kind of looking at culture
and trends and
deploying those opportunities.
So I don't know if I'm
doing a jack of all trades
'cause I'm doing, whether
it's wine or advertising
or whatever the heck I'm doing.
Or am I a master of one which is
I am so deeply entrenched into
my emotional intelligence around
one single thing called empathy
that is the seed that
reverses all the way back.
So I think even
the definition of that,
I could see
myself being either, or.
And I think we
spend so much time
debating things
like that, and the people
that ask those
kind of questions,
my answer is always just "Do".
Sitting around and
pondering the strategy
of being a master or
a jack instead of doing,
is a huge mistake. Linds
- [Lindsay] So on
a personal note,
we were talking about earlier,
how was your Father's Day?
- My Father's Day was amazing.
I was home, actually, last week.
So I got the little gifts
from my little ones
from school, the drawings.
I attended a Father's Day thing
at the little one's school.
They got us
singing and jumping around.
So it was, it
was really amazing.
- I think the Cannes Film
Festival is a terrible festival
because it's
actually during Father's Day.
And like, literally the fact
that they can't move it a week,
upsets me greatly.
So I have a half a
Father's Day every year
because I have to jump
on a late plane to get here
for all this stuff going on, so.
I'd like to use this
platform right now, to lobby
for a push back by one week.
Hope somebody here at
the Lions is listening.
- [Lindsay] Alright,
this is a very specific
question from
Jesse K., 16 years old,
from Upper Saddle River,
New Jersey.
- Yes, Jersey in the house.
- [Lindsay] Phone
number: 201-888-2730.
- Wow, sharing info.
- [Lindsay] Question regarding--
- Call 'em, freak 'em out.
- Teen entrepreneurship
and whether you should jump
at every opportunity,
when you're
trying to balance school
and business as
much as possible.
- [Black Coffee] Look,
in my experience,
I'll say jump, you know.
The sooner you jump, the better
because you learn so much
from trying and failing.
If you don't try now,
you might just try a
little bit too late, you know.
So, learn now while you're 16.
By 18 you'll have an
experience of some sort.
You'll know what to take and
what not to take, you know.
It doesn't matter
how many, you know.
I'm from that school
that always used to calculate,
and like no, I'm not ready.
And with growing up,
I've learned that actually
I've wasted so much
time on trying to plan things
that I don't even know.
You know, so I'd go all-in,
and I'll get that stress
as I get on with it, basically.
- I couldn't agree more.
I'm, there's so much
more up side than down side,
in taking risks at a young age,
it's just practical.
It's practical to go
high risk-high reward,
in your teens and 20s.
It's just life practical.
And I think the
reason people don't,
is they love their
parents, or grandparents,
or somebody in their life that
they don't want to disappoint
by doing the thing that
seems crazy to that elder.
And, you know, I don't
want to sit on a pedestal
and say, you know, do that.
I understand
what's stopping them.
I just want to challenge people
to recognize that
regret is very scary.
And what ends up happening is
you're protecting your
parents' feelings in your 20s
by doing the thing
you want them to do.
But how it manifests
is in a relationship
in your 40s, 50s,
and 60s with your parents
that is less healthy
because you start blaming them
for not taking those jumps.
And so I feel like you
can fight with your parents
now or later, and I just
think it works out much better
in the upfront.
- [Lindsay] So on the
other end of the spectrum,
Celeste Stewart,
who's watching all the way
from Cape Town, South Africa,
wants to know,
how do you deal with rejection?
- Um,--
- [Lindsay] Gary's like yes.
- Let me take it first,
and then he can take it.
Phenomenally.
I fuckin' love rejection.
I'm so blown away by
people's lack of understanding
that battle scars
are attractive.
Like, losses are sexy.
Like I love losing.
I love rejection.
I actually go the other way.
When I win, I get weird.
I hated winning.
- [Black Coffee] Same here.
- You?
- (laughs) Same here.
Especially me coming
from where I come from,
you know, I start
feeling bad for the guys that.
- Didn't make it?
- Didn't win, and you know,
but this is how I started.
My first album,
which came out in 2005
was an album of remixes,
and so I went around,
did my research, asking the guys
that were doing
what I was doing,
or what I was trying to do.
Is it worth it
doing an album of remixes?
They were like,
what do you mean?
I'm like, if I take all
the music that's around,
and remix it and
re-release it, you know,
do you think it
would be a success?
And everyone was
like, come on dude,
people know the
songs already, you know.
You're wasting your time.
This is how I started, you know.
And I felt very,
I believed in the idea so much
that I went ahead, you know.
And released an
album, as my first album,
and I won an
award for it, you know.
So my debut
album got me an award,
and it was an album of
remixes that I was told
it was never gonna make it.
So this is how I started,
and I feel the same
way about rejection.
It's always a way for me to say
I think that I'm
on the right track.
You know, the fact that a lot
of people aren't understanding
because we live in a world
where everyone is following.
Everyone is following, and
we wake up, and it's too late.
Someone goes the other
way, and they create Facebook.
You're like wow.
Why didn't we think of that?
You know I bet you Zuckerberg,
when he first came with an idea,
if he had put it
out there that he wanted
to create such a thing,
I don't think many people
would have agreed with him.
And that's how it is, you know.
I just think, find
power in rejection.
Use that power to
fuel you to do even better.
- Yeah I mean, to
me, the way I think,
I just, it's
basically a binary thing.
I think that
people that are attracted
and are obsessed
with losing tend to win.
Like it's such a
counter intuitive thing.
Like people are
always fascinated
why I talk on
this subject matter.
I don't know, I just really,
I love being a Jets fan
so much, like I love the losses.
I love the climb.
It's all the journey.
I mean, and on a personal
level, like that's something
that I can't control
and that's kind of haha.
On a personal level, like going
into my dad's liquor store
like I wasn't good enough
to get a job somewhere else.
Or going into the advertising
world, or Wine Library TV.
Being in the wine business,
doing something that everybody.
Everything that I've
ever done in my life,
has started off with I'm
an idiot, and I'm a loser.
And ended with I'm a
genius, and I'm a winner.
And the only way
you can actually do that
is that you don't
actually give a fuck about
what anybody else is saying.
Like that's what
it comes down to.
You're either the kind
of person that crumbles
at other people's opinions
about what you're up to,
or you're the kind of person
that stays in your own head,
in a fuckin' field with cows,
or just in your
own head in your bed,
and realize, I got this.
And it's gonna taste
so much, like I live for
I fuckin' told you.
I live for that.
Like I don't mind if
people think that's like weird
and like, it's the best feeling.
I love looking at
people's faces that didn't think
and rolling up, like
I've got a sports agency now.
My brother and I just started.
And we're trying
to sign these kids.
And they're going
with much bigger firms,
as they should, I get it.
But if you don't
think I can't wait
to Super Bowl in four years
or the ESPYs in two years,
and roll up on these
kids and say you fucked up.
Like that's what's driving
me to take bullshit flights
to Toledo to meet
their parents right now.
Literally, just the
fact that most people think
I'm too busy doing too
many things, and I can't.
So I deal with it tremendously.
- [Lindsay] So very relevant
to what
Steve Outwell says, or asks,
when you hit your
goals, how do you actually deal
with feeling worthy of them?
Which I think you just
answered, but it's a good point.
- I hate hitting goals.
Which is why I try not to
make them, other than buying.
Like I genuinely believe the
day I buy the New York Jets
is going to be a
weird day for me.
Like I don't, like I don't know.
I don't like hitting goals,
I don't like it.
I actually don't make goals.
I've got one that's on
the record, it's a big one,
it's gonna take me some time.
You?
- It's a weird
feeling for me as well.
I don't know, I think--
- It's a downer, right?
- the journey is more exciting.
You know, not knowing
what's going to happen for me,
it all is exciting.
Like waking up, not sure if
it's going to work out or not,
but try.
You know we keep
moving forward, you know.
I mean in all interviews,
for the past 5, 6 years,
I've been mentioning one name.
And like, who do you
want to collaborate with?
I'm like, Drake.
But they like, but
you doing house music.
I'm like, I also don't
know how its gonna happen.
But that's what I want.
You know, and why,
that I've always been saying
because I feel the kind
of house music that we do
is quite beautiful, but it
it's not accessible to all.
It doesn't have
that Beyonce
or the Drake budget.
So, it doesn't get
to many ears, you know.
But I'm here to wait
and try and make it work.
Until we got the call
from Drake's people one day,
saying let's do it.
You know, and
when that happened,
I couldn't even share it.
Even though it's been something
I've been chasing for years.
- Did you have the
feeling where you were pumped
for like three minutes
and then just like,
kind of moved forward?
- Of course, and people
that would be around me,
my wife,
my friends, they all say,
but you don't look excited.
Are you happy?
And I would say
yeah I'm, you know.
But I think what makes me
happy is the journey, you know.
- It's the next
thing, every time.
- Yep, yep.
- One more Linds.
- [Lindsay] Should
I ask the audience.
- No, go ahead there, we'll
jam with the audience separate
- [Lindsay] Alright,
so two questions
one question, two parts
(audience laughter)
Gary, how do you define
the grind versus the hustle,
and Coffee, how do you define
Matty, how do you define
inspiration versus motivation,
what's the difference?
- You start.
- Inspiration versus motivation.
I think, to inspire,
inspiration can come from
just words you can pick up
on Google, and just put
them up and inspire people.
To motivate people is
to get involved, you know,
one of the things I did
in 2010, that's the year
South Africa was
hosting World Cup.
I started a
DJ Black Coffee foundation
and the launch of it,
because I wanted
to motivate people
I set up a stage in
the middle of Soweto,
in a shopping center and
DJ'ed for 60 hours like,
from Thursday
midnight until Sunday midday.
That was motivation,
you know, for me that's the
difference between motivating
someone and inspiring someone.
I used that as a motivation
and I kept saying in interviews
when we were building up
to it, I want people to see
what I'm doing, and get
up and do something similar.
There's so many different
homes with people that are
in need in South Africa,
go there, spend a day,
do laundry, cook for them,
this is what I was trying to do
to motivate them to
get up and do something,
that's how I think
I define the two.
- It's so crazy, I've never
DJ'ed in my entire life,
when he was talking I was like,
I'm going to
fucking DJ for 61 hours
(audience laughter)
I'm so sick, I'm like
such a broken person, anyway.
I actually am gonna use this
opportunity to do something
for my audience that
I've wanted to speak about
for a while now, which
is, I don't define the grind
or the hustle in any
different words, like,
I think we're getting
too caught up in words,
especially my community,
we're trying to define all
these things, you can
call it, use the adjective,
that you want, I think
nobody should be confused,
I think it's a great
parlay off of what you said.
I'm trying to show people
the reason I do a daily vlog
is sure, I'm narcissistic
and want it on tape
and all that stuff and
it builds a brand and it'll
be fun to look at when I'm
80, but more than anything,
I'm suffocating out anybody's
excuse of what hard work
actually looks like, it's on
tape now, it's black and white.
There's no more debate, you
guys see it and by the way
I'm so thrilled to do this
literally for 28 straight years
so that it's so mundane
and boring it's the same old
grind and hustle, same old
thing, and so whether you use
the word grind or hustle or
work, a lot of people are like,
"Gary, you shouldn't use crush
it anymore, it's played out,
"use this, or I don't
like the word hustle,
"it can mean like..."
I mean, to debate the word,
the semantics of that shit is
such a waste of time, just
do the action, you understand
what it is, if you're
debating the word and trying to
have those conversations,
that's the excuse to buy time
- You're wasting
time yeah (laughing)
- to not actually do
it, that's exactly right.
Linds, thank you
so much, Black Coffee
- Thank you both.
- Follow this man,
clap it up, love this man.
Thanks for hanging with us.
Now my friend, oh yeah
I'll take that again, but, now
you get to ask the question
of the day, every time I have
a guest you get to ask, I'm
going to buy you some time
while you think of it,
you get to ask the question
of the day, thousands of people
across Youtube and Facebook
will answer it. You can
use this for market research,
you can use this for, you can
make it just silly or fun,
but you get to ask the question
of the day and they will
answer it so what's your
question for the Vayner Nation?
- I think
the human
generation of just humans are
in constant search of
happiness and people find it in
different things,
in work and play.
I think my question to
everyone is, and this
question is to inspire you,
maybe to get you up
and go find your own,
what is your happiness?
- [Gary] Love it.
Great question, my man.
Let's clap it up for this
wonderful human being.
You keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)